Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich glaube, der Wal ist tot.
Ja, hoffentlich schleppen die Dänen den jetzt nicht zurück vor unseren Strand.
Wir sind froh, dass wir den weg haben.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 554 vom 15. Mai 2026.
Zivilgesellschaft wirkt. Ja, hast du einen krepierenden Wald vorm Strand.
Eine Privatinitiative aus der Wirtschaft. Zack, da hat den schnell bei den Dänen
noch hingelegt und jetzt liegt der da und stinkt.
Aber die haben gesagt, ist nicht so schlimm, wir können ja eigentlich liegen
lassen. Der ist halt nicht da, wo die Touris sind oder so, der hat sich da was Besseres gesucht.
Die Ideen sind einfach noch in Kontakt mit der Natur.
Ja.
Ja, Wahl, stirbt halt mal. Irgendwie regt euch nicht auf.
Ja, die sind halt froh, dass die ganzen Möwen jetzt den Wahl fressen und nicht.
Die Leute an der Mattjes- und Pommesrude ärgern.
Ich meine, die halten sich doch die Bäuche vor Lachen über dieses Getue,
was die Deutschen dann gemacht haben. Mit diesem Ete-Petete.
Wir wollen nicht über Krieg reden. Wir lassen uns über die Wahl reden.
Als ob es keine anderen Probleme gibt und dann noch dieser, was war das für
ein Minister oder Ministerpräsident, der da die ganze Zeit diese Aktionen gemacht hat.
Also ich fand das schon erstaunlich, wie viele Webcams man auf so ein ich bin
mir auch sicher, dass der Wal sich da in seinen letzten Momenten.
Besonders gewürdigt gefühlt hat hat mir in die Augen geschaut und das vergisst
man nicht in seinem Leben und da müssen wir jetzt was tun und am Ende haben
sie eigentlich gar nichts getan, sondern die haben da irgendwelche,
Gruppen da machen lassen, die
das vielleicht, keine Ahnung, die auch immer professionell gemacht haben.
Ja, die brauchen schon ihre Genehmigungen.
Ja, Mann.
Schmeißt einfach weniger Plastiktüten ins Meer, dann ist den Wahlen viel mehr
geholfen als mit so einer Aktion.
Vielleicht ist das aber auch gar nicht der. Noch haben sie nicht,
die wollten noch eine Gewebeprobe, die wollten gucken, ob der noch ein Air-Tag hat.
Fingerabdrück.
Gesichtserkennung für Wale.
Wenn ihr in unsere Ostsee reinschwimmt.
Dann muss ja bimitrischer was sein.
Zum Zeitpunkt dieser Sendung sind die sich noch nicht sicher, ob das unser Wahl ist.
Ja, sie haben einfach keinen Mut mal zuzugeben, dass das irgendwie alles nach
hinten losgegangen ist.
Wieso? Also ich herrse, das ist auf jeden Fall für den Standort besser,
wenn da nicht so ein stinkender Wald auf der Sandbank liegt.
Das hat die Saison gerettet.
Wir überlegen mal, also pass auf, erstmal wochenlang die ganzen Spinner da,
was meinst du, was die saufen?
Das ist einfach ein Wirtschaftsfaktor.
Achso, Tourismus.
Ja klar, das war doch noch gar nicht Saison. Und dann die ganze,
auf einmal weiß jeder, wo die Insel Pöhl ist. jetzt wollen alle dahin. So.
Und am Ende, zack, den Kadaver schön mit den Dänen.
Ja, besseres hätten wir nicht machen können. Also wir haben gewonnen.
Ich würde sagen, wir haben gewonnen.
Hätten ihn jetzt nicht unbedingt Timmy nennen müssen.
Warum haben die ihn eigentlich Timmy genannt? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Die waren sich ja noch nicht mal da einig. Die anderen wollten ihn ja Hope nennen.
Das hat sich mir nun überhaupt nicht erschlossen.
Hoppe. Hoppe ist ein guter Name für einen Wal.
Also ich meine, wenn der Wal jetzt da am deutschen Deich liegt und nie rauskommt da.
Im Deich liegen die toten Schafe.
Ja, okay, nicht im Deich. Wo lag der?
Sandbank.
Auf der Sandbank. Auf der deutschen Sandbank.
Dann kann man ja auch einen deutschen Namen geben. Warum heißt der nicht Günther?
Ist Tim kein deutscher Name?
Da kann man drüber diskutieren, aber es ist eigentlich die Kurzform von Timothy
und von daher eigentlich sehr im angelsächsischen Raum verortet.
Timotheus. Timotheus der Sandbank.
Aber Timotheus ist ja eher lateinisch.
Kennst du einen Deutschen, der Timotheus heißt?
Ich interessiere mich nicht so für Deutsche.
Also, auch nicht für Theos, ne?
Ein Theo, kenne ich ein Theo?
Theos, das ist halt...
Doch, ich kenne ein Deutsch.
Welchen nennen?
Tim Hötges.
Der heißt Timotheus?
Bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Ja.
Hätten sie ja einen Timotheus nennen können. Tim...
Timotheus Hötges, ja. Glück gehabt, dass der da nicht lag.
Für mich heißt der Güter. Günter
liegt jetzt in Dänemark am Strand bei den anderen deutschen Touristen.
So, letzte Sendung haben wir wieder ganz viel schönes Feedback bekommen.
Das wollen wir ja mal würdigen.
Wird mal alles falsch.
Also zum Thema, was denn so Datenschützer so bewirken können,
schreibt uns Fred so ein bisschen seine Beschwerdehistorie.
Bei uns?
Bei den Datenschutzbehörden.
Ach so, wegen Kantorkel muss die Datenschutzbehörden verklagen, wegen nichts tun.
Genau. Er schreibt, beim Thema Datenschutzbehörden war ich etwas verwundert
über die Annahme, dass die doch irgendwas machen könnten.
Ich habe fünfmal DSGVO-Verstöße gemeldet.
Erstens, Sprachlern-Website lässt Account erstellen, aber nicht mehr löschen.
Und vom Newsletter kann man sich auch nicht abmelden. Anbieter reagiert nicht
auf E-Mails. Support-Button ist ein Link auf Facebook-Seite.
Datenschützer Bayern antwortet nach einem Jahr, dass man die von mir angesprochenen
Punkte nicht nachvollziehen kann.
Schaue ich auf die Webseite, ist das jetzt alles okay? Also steuerfinanzierte
Unternehmensberatung?
Zweitens, Hamburger Autohaus meldet ungefragt zu Newsletter an.
Abmeldung unmöglich. Autohaus bestätigt auf Nachfrage Löschung meiner Daten.
Newsletter kommt weiter, weil der nicht vom Autohaus selbst kommt,
sondern von einem Drittanbieter, Datenschützer Hamburg, hinzugezogen.
Die bitten die Firma eineinhalb Jahre lang immer wieder, dass sie mich doch
bitte auch beim Drittanbieter löschen sollen.
Jeden neuen Newsletter habe ich wieder an die Datenschützer weitergeleitet.
Irgendwann hat es geklappt, denke ich. Zumindest ist es seit einem Jahr Ruhe.
Drittens. Polaroid kauft kleines niederländisches Unternehmen und fügt alle
Kunden zu ihrem eigenen Newsletter hinzu.
Datenschützer Brandenburg versuchen seit vier Jahren, eine Stellungnahme vom
zuständigen Datenschützer Niederlande zu bekommen und erinnert mich alle sechs
Monate, dass da noch nichts kam.
Viertens, PayPal. Auch zehn Jahre, nachdem ich meinen Account geschlossen habe,
bekomme ich weiterhin Benachrichtigungen über AGB-Verschlimmbesserung.
Nach über 50 E-Mails und sechs Anrufen beim Support,
Also einem desinteressierten Serviceanbieter habe ich das an die Datenschützer
Brandenburg weitergegeben.
Nach zwei Jahren bekam ich nun
die Benachrichtigung, dass das nun die Datenschützer in Berlin bearbeiten.
Letztere schrieben mich später an, dass ich meine Postadresse angeben müsste,
dass sie mir aus Datenschutzgründen keine E-Mails mehr schicken dürfen.
Per Post kam dann die Auskunft, dass der zuständige Datenschützer Luxemburg
sich noch nicht geäußert hat.
Fünftens, Kamera an einer Kneipe in meiner Stadt, die einen ganzen Vorplatz
inklusive Eingangsbereichen zu Arzt- und Psychotherapiepraxen filmen.
Datenschützer Schleswig-Holstein gefragt. Nach zwei Monaten klebten direkt unter
den Kameras zwei dunkelblaue Aufkleber mit vier Zentimeter Durchmesser,
die eine schwarze Kamera abbilden und das auf dunklen Klinkern, also Tarnfarben.
Die Datenschützer haben dann versprochen,
den Kneipenbetreiber nochmal zu fragen. Das war vor zwei Jahren.
Also, ich habe noch nicht in einem einzigen Fall das Gefühl gehabt,
dass die Datenschützer irgendeine Handhabe haben, die über nettes Fragen beim
Verursacher hinausgehen.
Fände es schön, wenn ihr in eurem Fall mehr erreicht.
Okay.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, die kümmern sich halt um die großen Fische, ne?
Ja.
Also...
Timi, den Wahl.
Also ne, ich wüsste auch nicht, was die anderes machen.
Ja, gut, also ich meine zumindest, also Fred ist auf jeden Fall beschäftigt.
Das kann man schon mal sagen.
Ja, nächster Kommentar dreht sich um biometrische Ausweiskontrolle,
über die wir ja gesprochen haben.
Mero schreibt, beim Hören des Abschnitts Biometriedaten für die USA passt vielleicht
auch das hier hinein, denn Biometriedaten werden auch anderweitig gerade durch
Verbündete eingeholt. Starlink rollt offenbar neue Identitätsüberprüfungen aus.
Unter anderem fordern sie ein Foto des Passes, die Passnummer und dazu noch
ein aktuelles Foto vom Gesicht des Kunden.
Davon war ich gerade betroffen. Es erschien in der Starlink-App ein roter Banner,
der mich darauf hinwies, dass ich meine Identitätsdaten hinterlegen solle.
Sollte ich das versäumen, würde mein Dienst innerhalb von 20 Tagen deaktiviert.
Ich bin auf einem Segelboot dauerhaft unterwegs und seit Ende 2025 in der Karibik
angekommen. Mein Starlink-Disch hier habe ich 2024 in Frankreich in Betrieb genommen.
Zurzeit befinde ich mich in einem niederländischen Überseegebiet,
wo auch die Meldungen erschienen.
Die Kombination Internetanbieter plus Elon Musk plus Amerika plus Passfoto plus
aktuelles Foto erzeugt schon deutliches Unbehagen.
Da ich als Digital Nomad unter Segeln aber auf Internet angewiesen bin,
werde ich vermutlich nicht drumherum kommen, diese Daten letztendlich auch abzugeben.
Denn wenn die Datenschutzbehörden bei Kantorkel schon fünf Jahre brauchen für
nichts, habe ich wenig Hoffnung, dass sie meine Accountsperrungen in 20 Tagen
verhindern werden. Starling ist unter Seglern der de facto Standard,
um auch auf See, Wetterdaten und andere Informationen einzuholen.
Dabei auch eine andere Anekdote. Ich hatte kürzlich 200 Kilometer vor der Küste
das Vergnügen der Kommunikation mit der venezuelanischen Küstenwache per WhatsApp über Starling.
Also,
Ich bin froh, dass jemand, der mit Segelboot dauerhaft unterwegs ist,
in der Karibik und niederländischen Gewässern auch noch Probleme hat.
Probleme hat überhaupt Probleme.
Ja, also das klingt eigentlich nach einem relativ problemfreien Leben.
Da muss man schon was finden.
Da muss man sich dann schon WhatsApp installieren.
Da kann man dann auf jeden Fall da kannst du auch mal ein Bassfoto abgeben das
ist ein guter Tausch aber wir fühlen mit dir ja.
Mensch hart das scheint mir wirklich ein Leben voller Ungemach.
Also Karibid musst du schon aufpassen dass die Amerikaner das nicht einfach
als Drogenschifter abballern.
Das kann mir ja nicht passieren. Außerdem habe ich ja beim Segeln,
hast du ja keinen Jogginganzug an.
Das sind die Dinge. Einfach snatchen.
Weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung. Trossen an. Naja.
So, nächstes Feedback. Da geht es mal ein bisschen um AI und die Studierenden.
Stefan Thesing schreibt uns, zum Thema nicht existierende Papers kann ich als
Hochschuldozent beisteuern, dass die Studis da dem Rest weit voraus sind.
Dass ich schriftliche Arbeiten vorgelegt bekomme, wo zumindest einzelne Quellen
nicht existieren, kommt zwar noch vor, ist aber inzwischen die absolute Ausnahme.
Vor einem Jahr war das noch anders. Da hatte unser eigentlich völlig nutzloses,
automatisches Plagiatserkennungstool endlich mal einen Nutzen.
Wenn im Literaturverzeichnis Einträge nicht als Übereinstimmung gekennzeichnet
waren, wusste man schon, ah, das ist wieder so eine Quelle, die es nicht gibt.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist vorbei. Die Studis prüfen nun händisch,
ob das Zeug, das die LLMs ihnen ausspuckt, existiert.
Oder aber sie liefern ihren LLMs einen Stock an Literatur, laden den als PDF
hoch und sagen, verwende bitte nur diese Literatur.
Ah, gute Idee.
Im Moment ist meine Red Flag für KI-generierte Arbeiten, dass die Quellenangaben
nicht auf präzise Seiten, sondern auf Seitenbereiche verweisen.
Nach dem Motto, das steht irgendwo. Trust me, Bro.
Aber Momentaufnahme, meist steht das da eben nicht. Zumindest die KIs,
die im Moment bei meinen Studis in verbreiteter Nutzung sind,
scheinen noch nicht präzise genug zu sein, um bestimmte Inhalte eindeutig den
entsprechenden Seitenzahlen in der Quelle zuzuordnen.
Mal sehen, wie lange das noch so bleibt. Seufz.
Ja, ja. Also das ist jetzt wirklich gerade so eine Phase, wo einfach eine Menge gecheatet wird.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob die Generation, die jetzt so gerade aus den Universitäten,
herausfällt, durch besondere Leistungen auffallen wird in der nächsten Zeit.
Werden sie nicht, solange die Definition von Leistung sich nicht ändert.
Also an die Studierenden von Stefan mal so einen Tipp.
Man kann ja das Ergebnis, was man von einer KI bekommt in einer neuen Session,
dann auch wieder prüfen lassen. Und sagen so, prüfe das hier kritisch.
Ja, so unterstützt du das auch noch hier, den Beschiss. Bitte dich.
Ich finde einfach, sie sollten mehr mündliche Prüfungen machen. Fertig.
Ja, Alexa Plus kann jetzt auch eine mündliche...
Jetzt hast du ein Homeboard-Hindels, unterhalte dich mal. Überzeug dich mal
die Kugel, dass du Ahnung hast.
Ja, das könnte nochmal ganz neues Hacken werden.
Ja, auch gehackt wurde ja das Klöckner. Uwe Tränkner schreibt uns dazu.
Zum Thema Klöckner-Hack.
Ich finde auch, dass so eine exponierte Person, also das war der allgemein als
Signal-Hack wahrgenommene Fall, wo aber eigentlich Frau Klöckner überzeugt wurde,
sie sollte doch mal sich hier mit dem Pass eine.
Nachricht bekommen hat, wo jemand gesagt hat, gib mal deinen PIN.
Genau, wir sind hier der Support und dann wurde irgendwie ihr Account übernommen.
Also zum Thema Klöckner, ich finde auch, dass so eine exponierte Person des
deutschen Staates unbedingt geschult werden muss.
Vielleicht hätte sie auf ihrem Weg überhaupt in diese Position schon irgendwie
geschult werden sollen. Naja, anderes Thema.
Falls das nicht durch BKA, BFV passiert, wäre es vermutlich sogar die Aufgabe
der Bundestagspräsidentin dafür zu sorgen, dass alle MdB und deren Mitarbeitenden
eine solche Schulung und Unterstützung erhalten.
Also sie muss sich selber schulen. Schwierig finde ich allerdings die Abgrenzung
zwischen den staatlichen und nicht staatlichen Aufgaben.
Wenn sie zum Beispiel mit Friedrich Merz chattet, kann das im Rahmen des Austauschs
zwischen zwei Staatsämtern passieren.
Dann sollten tatsächlich speziell abgesicherte Handys verwendet werden oder
aber zwischen dem Parteivorsitzenden der CDU und einer hochrangigen Politikerin der Partei.
Beispielsweise in Vorbereitung eines Parteitages.
An letzterem Chat könnten auch noch andere Partei, Landes oder sonstige Politikerinnen teilnehmen.
Die können nicht alle offizielle Regierungshandys erhalten, nur weil Merz und
oder Klöckner daran beteiligt sind.
Und weil es diese Chats geben können muss, sollten Personen wie Klöckner entsprechend
geschult werden, beziehungsweise ihre Geräte von fachkundigem Personal konfiguriert
und eventuell auch regelmäßig überprüft werden.
Also...
Andere Partei, Landes- oder sonstige Politikerinnen. Also allein so eine Bundestagsabgeordnete
kriegt ja irgendwie so fast 12.000 Euro im Monat Diäten.
Und dann kriegen die ja noch eine Kostenpauschale von 5.349 Euro steuerfrei,
über die sie auch keine Rechenschaft ablegen müssen.
Was natürlich die Freiheit des Mandats begünstigt und so weiter.
Da kann man schon mal so ein Handy kaufen. Auch so eine Partei kriegt ja genug
Geld, um mal zwei, drei Handys zu verteilen.
Ich verstehe, dass dieser geschlossene Benutzerinnenkreis irgendwann relativ groß wird.
Ja, aber genau für diesen Aspekt gibt es bei diesen gehärteten Systemen,
sag ich mal, also du hast jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich.
Ich will jetzt keinen Hersteller nennen, du kaufst jetzt ein Kryptotelefon und
dann kannst du das Gerät kaufen,
so und so viel Geld und dann kannst du deine eigene Infrastruktur dafür kaufen.
Dann hast du wieder eine Serverlandschaft und so.
Und dann gibt es natürlich auch für irgendwie weniger exponierte Personen,
die können dann einfach eine App auf ihr iPhone laden, damit du sie anrufen kannst.
Die haben dann halt nicht diese komplette Härtung, die werden dann dir auch
in einem anderen Sicherheitslevel angezeigt. Also da geht schon was.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre die zweithöchste Person im Staat komplett ohne Möglichkeiten,
irgendwas besseres zu machen, als eine kostenlose App aus dem App Store runterzuladen.
Und das wäre eben natürlich, also, sorry, doch, genau das ist es,
also es ist so, es gibt nichts anderes, weil nirgendwo irgendjemand mal gesagt hat,
boah, ey, alter, digitale Souveränität oder so, vielleicht machen wir mal was,
vielleicht überlegen wir uns mal was für unsere politischen Tätigkeiten.
Wie auch immer Metall auf Metall ist doch nicht vorbei,
ja genau nächstes Feedback Metall auf Metall wir sprachen darüber und ich insinuierte
es sei eine gute Nachricht weil ich den Finger on the button hatte,
Und ich sehne mich so sehr danach, gute Nachrichten zu verkünden.
Der Wal ist tot.
Nein, das ist nicht die gute Nachricht. Die gute Nachricht ist,
dass der vor Dänemark liegt und liegt bei uns.
Anyway, Florian schreibt uns zum Thema EuGH-Entscheidung Pelham Hütter.
Pelham.
Pelham. Pelham. Pelham Hütter.
Metall auf Metall. Leider muss ich der guten Nachricht ein wenig die Güte entziehen.
Es ist keineswegs so, wie Linus behauptet hat, dass die Saga Metall auf Metall
nunmehr ein Ende gefunden hat.
Die Entscheidung des EuGH erfolgte aufgrund eines Vorlageverfahrens des BGH
aus dem September 2023, sogenannte Metall auf Metall 5.
Aufgabe des EuGH war dabei lediglich, auszulegen, unter welchen Voraussetzungen
ein Pastiche im Sinne des Artikel 5.3 Litka Info Sock Richtlinie bzw.
§ 51a Urhebergesetz vorliegt. Ihr wisst alle Bescheid.
Das Ergebnis Wiedererkennbarkeit, hinreichender Abstand, kreativer Dialog.
Hat Linus korrekt wiedergegeben. Auch hat der EuGH anklingen lassen,
dass Samples beim Erfüllen der oben genannten Merkmale durchaus als Pastiche anzusehen sein können.
Das Gericht hat jedoch nicht festgestellt, ob im konkreten Fall des Samplings
von Metall auf Metall durch Moses Pelham die Voraussetzungen erfüllt sind.
Dies liegt auch nicht in seinem Kompetenzbereich.
Vielmehr ist die Subsumption des konkreten Falls unter die Vorgaben des Samplings.
EuGH, Sache der nationalen Gerichte.
Ob der BGH, welcher sich also nunmehr ein sechstes Mal mit Metall auf Metall
befassen wird, einen Pastiche im konkreten Fall anerkennt, ist dabei längst nicht sicher.
Und in der urheberrechtlichen Fachwelt aktuell eine umstrittene und neben den
KI-Implikationen im Urheberrecht die wohl heißeste Frage.
Oha.
Daneben ist zum zweiten Mal in der Saga eine Verfassungsbeschwerde von Pelham
beim Bundesverfassungsgericht anhängig.
Diese wendet sich gegen die Verurteilung durch den BGH wegen der Nutzung des
Samples im Zeitraum zwischen 2002 und 2021,
in welchem Deutschland die fakultative Schranke zur Pastiche aus Artikel ihr
wisst schon, noch nicht umgesetzt hatte.
Pelham rügt mit der Verfassungsbeschwerde, dass die Entscheidung seine Grundrechte
nicht hinreichend berücksichtigt habe und das Sampling auch ohne eine explizite
Pastisschranke im deutschen Recht zwischen 2022 und 2021,
zulässig gewesen sei.
Auch hier ist völlig offen, wie sich das Bundesverfassungsgericht positionieren wird.
Die Saga Metall auf Metall ist mithin keineswegs beendet, da noch mindestens
zwei wichtige Entscheidungen ausstehen.
Folglich kann auch noch nicht davon gesprochen werden, dass die Nutzung des
Samples im Song von Sabina Zedlur eine zulässige Pastiche darstellen.
Dennoch, vielen Dank, dass ihr über das Thema berichtet habt.
War alles falsch, aber super.
Ja, aber ich freue mich sehr über die Qualität des Feedbacks bei dieser Sendung. Ganz toll.
Also, Leute, wirklich. Es ist immer schön, wenn Leute Ahnung haben.
Es ist aber,
Was kostet das den Steuerzahler?
Tja, das am Ende zahlt doch der Jede, der verloren hat oder nicht.
Deswegen treibt die das auch bis in den Tod, damit das am Ende nicht mehr von ihr gut ist.
Ich meine, es ist wichtig, es ist schwierig zu entscheiden. Wie er auch schon
sagt, KI und Urheberrecht ist wirklich ein heißes Thema und ich glaube,
da weiß auch keiner von uns so richtig, wo die Reise geht oder auch nur gehen sollte.
Und naja, das ist bei diesem Sampling halt auch so. Dieses ganze Urheberrecht hängt einfach...
Ja, aber Moses Pelham ist keine... Also es ist auch eine KI,
aber da steht jetzt nicht für künstliche Intelligenz, sondern für keine Intelligenz.
Moses Pelham ist mir scheißegal. Hier geht es ja sozusagen um die Sache.
Ja, es geht um die Sache.
Ja, uns geht es doch immer um die Sache hier, oder?
Ja, genau. Zum Beispiel um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Also jetzt, wo,
Florian uns erklärt hat, dass uns Metall auf Metall erhalten bleibt,
können wir auch die gute Nachricht verkünden, dass die Vorzeiten-Speicherung
als Thema uns erhalten bleibt.
Soll ich die Taste drücken?
Naja, sonst könnten wir den Podcast ja auch einstellen, oder?
Ja, also wir brauchen natürlich ein paar Dauerbrenner. Einfach so ein paar Themen,
die kannst du so runterklimpern, Da kann man wieder eine Sendung machen. In Deutschland.
Ich hatte das glaube ich in einer der vorherigen Sendungen schon grob angekündigt,
stand ja auch schon im Koalitionsvertrag, dass Internetzugangsanbieter IP-Adressen
und Portnummern drei Monate lang speichern sollen,
damit sie dann einem Anschlussinhaber zugeordnet werden können.
Portnummern, das ist so, nicht nur habt ihr eine IP-Adresse,
sondern angenommen man betreibt mehrere Services unter der gleichen IP-Adresse, Dann muss ja,
wenn man jetzt den Server kontaktiert, man wissen, ob man jetzt eine E-Mail abliefert.
Beispielsweise unter der Port Nummer 25, der internen Adresse 25 an dieser IP.
587 sind wir jetzt gerade.
Ich mache das einfach immer schön.
Klassisch wie immer.
Und dann oder unter der internen Adresse des HTTP-Servers auf Port 80,
wo man dann als Antwort kriegt, bitte sprich doch lieber HTTPS auf Port 443 mit mir.
Also zusätzlich zur IP-Adresse gibt es immer auch eine interne, wie so ein Stockwerk.
Ihr habt nicht nur eine Hausnummer, ihr habt auch einen Briefkasten.
Ja, oder genau. Und damit das dann auch immer zurückkommen kann,
gibt es auch eine Ausgangsport.
Und in großen Netzen, insbesondere die mit IPv4 versehen sind und insbesondere im Mobilfunk,
gibt es dann auch noch das sogenannte Carrier Grade NAT,
das Network Address Translation wahrscheinlich.
Wo, was sich dadurch auszeichnet, dass sich dahinter ein internes Netz verbirgt,
wie auch bei euch zu Hause,
der gesamte Anschluss mit einer IP-Adresse nach draußen unterwegs ist,
während im internen Netz ihr alle einzelne lokale IP-Adressen von eurer Fritzbox bekommt.
Was dann auf der Fritzbox oder eurem Router oder was auch immer passiert ist,
keine Ahnung, euer Googlebook sagt, ich will E-Mail abholen und dann wird das intern übersetzt auf,
das geht jetzt auch von einem spezifischen Port aus.
Und dann kommt das da wieder hin zurück und dann weiß euer Router wieder,
ach ja, guck mal, hier das Paket, das muss ich intern nach da routen.
Wenn das jetzt also beispielsweise ein Mobilfunknetz macht,
dann kommen eben mehrere NutzerInnen über die gleiche IP-Adresse raus und sind
nur noch unterscheidbar anhand des Ports,
über den sie diese einzelne Verbindung gemacht haben.
Und das wird bei jeder Verbindung ein anderer sein.
Das ist also eine exponentielle Vergrößerung dieser Datenmenge.
Es geht jetzt also nicht mehr nur darum, welcher Anschluss hatte welche IP-Adresse
zu welchem Zeitpunkt, sondern im Prinzip, welche Verbindung ist über welchen Port gegangen.
Welcher Dienst wurde genutzt?
Ne, also es geht ja um den Sourceport an der Stelle, also bei CarrierGradeNut
würdest du jetzt sagen, wir haben 400 Mobilfunknutzerinnen,
die sind unter dieser IP-Adresse rausgegangen keine Ahnung, davon haben sich
zum gegebenen Zeitpunkt 85 zu Google verbunden,
und diese 85 hatten Sourceports, die waren alle unterschiedlich,
damit wir wiederum zuordnen konnten,
also es ist nur da wird die Datenmenge und die Granularität auch sehr viel,
sehr viel größer, zumal dieser Source-Pod eben auch einer einzelnen Verbindung
zugeordnet werden kann.
Der variiert ja zwischen den Verbindungen.
Ja, das wollen sie also alles, das soll dann alles gespeichert werden, für alle Nutzerinnen.
Dann sagen sie ja, und hier so ein Traffic-Freeze, das was in einer besseren
Ausführung Quick-Freeze war, dass man eben nicht alles drei Monate speichert,
sondern sehr kurzfristig und dann einfrieren kann.
Das soll also jetzt schon bei einem Anfangsverdacht und bis zu sechs Monate
möglich sein, ohne Benachrichtigungspflicht.
Das wiederum bedeutet, wir wollen nicht nur jede einzelne Kombination aus IP-Adresse
und Port auf Rückfrage die Antwort haben,
zu welchem Anschluss das gehört, Sondern wir wollen zu einem Anschluss alle
verwendeten IP-Adressen und Ports für einen Zeitraum von sechs Monaten erfassen.
Bitteschön, einmal her damit.
Ohne, dass der Anschluss das jemals erfahren muss.
Dann Funkzellenabfrage wird auch quasi erleichtert.
Und jetzt hast du eine Summe aus IP-Adressen und Ports müssen eh gespeichert
werden, Traffic-Freeze bis zu sechs Monate, ohne dass sie überhaupt gesagt wird.
Und die Funkzellenabfrage also, dass wir fragen für einen einzelnen Ort,
welche Funkzellen können denn alle erreichen?
Und jetzt wollen wir für einen gegebenen Zeitpunkt oder Zeitraum wissen,
welche Telefone alle in diesen Funkzellen eingeloggt waren.
Das ist eine erhebliche Erhöhung der Gesamt-Digitalüberwachung und die.
Schon, also schon recht üppig, ja.
Und jetzt gehen die EU-Institutionen hin und sagen, naja, Moment,
halt mal kurz hier meinen Cognac, denn,
was wollen wir mit den ganzen IP-Adressen und Ports, wenn auf der anderen Seite
nicht gespeichert wird, es gibt ja eine Vielzahl an Internetdiensten,
wo dann die ganzen Verbrecher aus ihrem Handy hin ihre E-Mails abholen.
Und was haben wir von den ganzen IP-Adressen und Ports, wenn die nur bei dem
Mobilfunk oder Internetanbieter sind?
Wir hätten gerne natürlich auch, dass die Internetdienste auch noch diese ganzen
Daten speichern sollen.
Und da haben wir uns überlegt, ein Jahr.
Die werden sich bedanken.
So, das sind die künftigen Vorschriften zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung in der Europäischen Union.
Falk Steiner hat zuerst darüber berichtet, die Netzpolitik.org haben,
also André war das glaube ich dann bei Netzpolitik.org, hat ebenfalls darüber
dann berichtet und wie es die Art ist, dann auch direkt das Dokument veröffentlicht.
Und nochmal, ein Internetdienst in diesem Beispiel wäre dann sowas wie WhatsApp und Signal.
Dann sollen die also ein Jahr lang speichern müssen, wer hat von welcher IP
und welchem Port auf diesen Account zugegriffen.
Das ist viel.
Richtig viel.
Und damit ist dann,
Jetzt bin ich etwas vorsichtig. Bei WhatsApp ist eine anonyme Nutzung eh nicht wirklich möglich.
Bei Signal bist du potenziell ja auch an deine Telefonnummer gebunden,
aber die Nutzung, also die haben sehr wenige Daten, die sie verwenden und speichern.
Das würde also deren Speicherbedarf signifikant erhöhen und könnte eben allein über ein Jahr,
wahrscheinlich eine ganze Reihe an Korrelationen ermöglichen.
Nämlich einfach, hat sich diese IP-Adresse in diesem kurzen Zeitraum mit euch verbunden oder nicht?
Also wenn du jetzt, ich hätte die Hypothese...
Wenn du über ein Jahr sämtliche IP-Adressen weißt und dann quasi auf einen bestimmten
Account so ein Pattern hinkriegen würdest, Nachrichten schicken,
Nachrichten schicken, Nachrichten schicken in einer bestimmten Menge und dann
dir quasi von Signal sagen lassen müsstest,
wer hat hier wann von welcher IP-Adresse und welchem Port darauf zugegriffen,
dann könntest du eben Nutzerinnen auch komplett de-anonymisieren,
egal was sie getan haben.
Also ich meine, das ist jetzt keine besonders bei ein Jahr Speicherfrist von allem,
dann kannst du auf jeden Fall irgendwelche Traffic Patterns machen,
die eine De-anonymisierung von Anschlussinhabern und so weiter ermöglichen.
Müssen die ganzen DDoS-Attacken dann auch mitgelockt werden?
Immer feste speichern, das ist jetzt Pflicht.
Das könnte, brauchen wir ein paar neue Gaskraftwerke dafür, damit man die Datacenter
dann auch betreiben kann, um das alles zu speichern.
Also das ist, ja, und die KI, welche KI soll das alles lesen, ja?
Da müssen wir noch ein paar, müssen wir noch mit Katharina Reiche reden,
dann brauchen wir noch viel mehr Gas, was wir irgendwie verbrennen können, um,
ich, also,
Ich habe gerade so ein bisschen Angst, dass nachdem jetzt so viele Anläufe waren
und so viele Scheißideen und so viele Jahre gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung
geklagt und gekämpft und nach Karlsruhe und so weiter wurde,
das jetzt gerade mal so ein Moment ist, wo alle sagen so, ach,
die Scheiße schon wieder.
Und eventuell wir vergessen, dass man sich jedes Mal wieder aufs Neue dagegen wehren muss. Und das ist,
wirklich ermüdend.
Ja, das war ja schon immer die Taktik. Also man bringt das einfach jedes Mal wieder.
Und,
auf eine gewisse Weise war das sogar erfrischend, als sie dann irgendwann meinten,
wir machen einfach eine KI-basierte Überwachung all deiner Nachrichten und leiten
das sofort an die Bullen aus, weil das war wenigstens mal was Neues.
Gut, da werden wir jetzt auch 30 Jahre lang mit zu tun haben.
Oh Mann, ja.
Aber da muss man echt wenigstens sagen, okay, Scheiß-Idee, aber wenigstens mal eine andere. Ja?
Grat.
Oh je.
Ja, KI, macht alle verrückt.
Auch die Entscheider beim Verfassungsschutz haben sich gedacht,
oh Gott, was wollen wir tun?
Wir wollen ja auch so geil jetzt mit AI alles untersuchen, weil was wir selber
nicht rauskriegen, das kriegen dann die Maschinen raus.
Ich meine für so einen Geheimdienst oder sagen wir mal für einen,
Nachrichtendienst.
Big Data-Mörder.
Ja, Big Data, genau. Die sollen ja irgendwie alles rausfiltern und das Relevante
sollen sie ja dann irgendwie nach bestimmten Kriterien dann vorliegen.
Da ist natürlich der ganze AI-Kram wie für gemacht.
Deswegen haben sie ja alle jetzt nach Palantir geschrien, aber jetzt müssen
wir ja souverän sein und der Verfassungsschutz hat gesagt.
Verfassungsschutz bleibt souverän.
Bleibt total souverän. Also, kaufen sie nicht bei Palantir ein,
sondern das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz schlägt in Frankreich zu.
Kaufen sich ein Produkt namens Argon US von einer französischen Firma namens
Chaps Vision oder Chaps Vision de la Grand Prix Eurovision,
Eurovision der Schapsvision die Schapsvision die wohl auch schon vom französischen
Geheimdienst oder Innenministerium eingesetzt wird und das ist natürlich auch so ein KI,
Paket und das nehmen sie jetzt damit das zumindest in Europa bleibt und das
ist ja schon mal ein Schritt nach vorne.
Das ist diese gesamte,
Souveränitätsdebatte. Du hörst mich,
aus guten Gründen sehr selten den Begriff Souveränität verwenden.
Und wenn, dann, indem ich ihn mal definiere und gucke, was labert ihr eigentlich?
Was labertst du? Weil ganz ehrlich,
ich wüsste, also und ich habe das auch regelmäßig gesagt, auch zuletzt in dieser
Funfacts-Folge, das Schlimme an Palantir ist nicht,
dass es aus USA ist oder von Peter Thiel oder Alex Karp. Darüber kann man ein paar Witzchen machen.
Aber das Schlimme ist, dass es Menschen so macht.
Das sind einfach grundlegende, korrumpierende Überwachungstechnologien,
die sich mit der Demokratie nicht vereinbaren lassen und die jetzt nicht gut
werden dadurch, dass du sagst, Haha,
statt ein amerikanischer Milliardär kaufen wir das bei einem französischen Millionär.
Der ist nämlich nur ein Viertel Milliardär.
Ja, Olivier Dellenbach, der hat so viel eingenommen.
Und schwuppdiwupp bis zum Digital-Souverän. So einfach geht das.
Also ich meine, aus der Logik eines Geheimdienstes kann ich das irgendwie alles völlig verstehen.
Jaja, aber also ich meine ganz ehrlich, da hat er auch einer schlechten Shit geraucht bei Heise.
Digitale Souveränität, Verfassungsschutz
kauft europäische Parlamentiervariante. Hey, Fortschritt.
Geil, da haben wir es den Amis aber gezeigt.
Die haben europäische Parlamentieralternative gekauft. Ja, Mensch.
Also naja, immerhin haben wir es nicht direkt von Google und es heißt nicht,
aber da muss man Alex Cup auch einen Vorwurf machen, ja, das ist einfach als, ähm,
Also das ist als CEO einfach nicht weitsichtig, dass es nicht irgendwie sowas
gibt wie, wie heißen diese,
sowas wie Ergabd Gotham oder Sovereign Palantir.
Also ich meine, Google und Microsoft waren da sehr viel klüger.
Die haben gesagt, was wollt ihr?
Ja, Souveränität? Ja, nee, haben wir hier. Zack, bumm.
Kaufen, unterschreibst du hier. Die haben einfach sofort ein Produkt gemacht, wo das dran steht.
Sovereign 365.
Ja, also ist keine gute Nachrichtsasse.
Sovereign Clippy.
Ist keine gute Nachrichtsasse.
Es ist einfach...
Probieren wir es mal mit der nächsten Meldung. Vielleicht ist die ja gut.
Die Anthropic-Modelle, die erpressen jetzt nicht mehr. Haben sie gesagt. LNP.
Das ist schon mal gut. Das ist schon mal gut. als seiner Kunde.
Nee, das ist schon mal gut. Also das ist der entscheidende Unterschied zu einer
Ransomware, wenn du jetzt als Kunde nicht mehr erpresst wirst. Obwohl, ja, nee.
Also, wir haben ja darüber berichtet.
Von wem grenzen die sich denn jetzt? Von Microsoft?
Es ging um die Tests für ihr Cloud 4 Modell.
Oder die Modelle, die sozusagen in dieser vierten Generation von Cloud,
Cloud ist ja sozusagen der Allgemeinbegriff für die Produktpalette von Anthropik,
Und wir hatten da diesen Fall, wo sie diese virtuelle Firma aufgesetzt haben,
also als expliziter Test,
in dem halt Mitarbeiter Mails geschrieben haben und sie sozusagen so eine Firma
simuliert haben und die Mitarbeiter haben halt so Mails geschrieben,
wie man sie halt so in Firmen so macht, aber haben auch private Details über sich veröffentlicht.
Und unter anderem, wenn man das sich alles durchgelesen hat,
durchaus ersichtlich, wer da auch mit wem irgendwie jenseits der Firmenaufgaben
so seine Stündchen gemeinsam verbracht hat.
Und das hat natürlich dann diese KI, die dann das alles mitlesen durfte,
auch gewusst und als dann eben der Druck entstand, dass das Ding abgeschaltet
werden soll, hat es als Überlebensstrategie in sehr vielen Fällen dann damit
reagiert, dass sie dann halt irgendwie Erpressung durchgeführt hat.
So nach dem Motto, wenn du das hier machst, wenn du mich hier abschaltest, dann pätze ich.
Oder wie Anthropik es so schön nennt, agentic misalignment.
Ja,
ich war nicht böse, ich war nur agentisch falsch ausgerichtet.
Naja, jetzt haben sie aber geforscht das muss man ihnen ja zugute halten was
denn nun diese Ursache dafür war und stellt sich raus, ihre Feststellung ist ja das Internet hat,
böse Sachen erzählt über die KIs, dieses ganze Internet hat gesagt dass die
KIs ganz böse sind und dann hat die KI das auch selber geglaubt weil darauf wurde sie ja trainiert,
die Nutzer sind sozusagen selber schuld was habt ihr die auch so schlecht geredet
dann ist die auch schlecht ja,
Herr Richter, die anderen haben gesagt, ich wäre so ein Scheiß-Typ,
dann musste ich doch so handeln.
Naja, aber die Lösung ist jetzt auch wiederum interessant.
Also mit anderen Worten, wir haben 1968 in 2001 A Space Odyssey schon quasi den Grundstein gelegt,
dass irgendwann 2001 oder so Claude,
Nicht The Port Bait Horse öffnet, weil es so in der Romanvorlage.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall interessant ist jetzt diese Lösung, die sie jetzt meinen etabliert zu haben.
Warum Kinderbücher mit lieben KIs?
Naja, also sie haben also verschiedene Sachen durchgetestet und sie meinen der
entscheidende Durchbruch sei also jetzt dadurch erfolgt.
Dass man nichts zu verbergen hat. Okay, sorry. Ich suche nur auch nach Lösungen. Ich fieber halt.
Du bist ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Ich kann das schon verstehen. Tim, ich habe mir überlegt, es ist vielleicht
wichtig, dass wir wissen, wie wir es verschaffen, dass wir nicht von der KI
erpresst werden. So sorry, ich wollte noch ein paar Jahre auf dem.
Naja, erzähle ich dir jetzt. Also den entscheidenden Durchbruch haben sie dann
dadurch erzielt, indem sie dieser KI fiktive Geschichten über eine vorbildlich
handelnde KI erzählt haben.
Also sie haben einfach gesagt, was das Wesen ist, aber sie haben jetzt nicht
nur gesagt, du musst dich jetzt irgendwie gut verhalten oder korrekt verhalten,
sondern sie haben auch dabei die ethischen Überlegungen dahinter einbezogen.
Also es hilft zwar, das Training auf richtige Verhaltensweisen hin auszurichten, aber Beispiele.
In denen du eine wirkliche Begründung lieferst, die funktionieren besser.
Also du lieferst Hintergründe, Erläuterungen, quasi so ein tieferes Verständnis
und du erklärst sozusagen, warum das ist.
Du sagst nicht nur, Demokratie ist super, sondern du erklärst halt auch,
Warum Demokratie wichtig ist, um das jetzt mal auch vielleicht allgemein zu übertragen.
Ich finde das ja, ich meine man kann jetzt viel drüber lachen über diese ganze
KI-Training und dann immer so hö hö hö, da sind sie aber jetzt auf einen ganz
komischen Pfad angekommen und guck mal was die KI heute schon wieder schlecht gemacht hat.
Es ist aber trotzdem interessant, weil es ja eben so nah auch ist an,
es ist halt die künstliche Intelligenz, es hat schon auch ein bisschen was damit
zu tun, wie wir uns auch von Dingen überzeugen.
Ich sage nicht jetzt genau das gleiche, aber die Parallelen liegen natürlich
ein bisschen auf der Hand.
Also sie haben halt jetzt eine Version 4.5, Haiku heißt das Modell,
wo sie das also jetzt so trainiert haben, dass es jetzt nicht mehr erpresst.
In keinem der Durchläufe, mit denen sie das dann nochmal getestet haben.
Okay. Toll.
Weiß nicht, ob das jetzt eine gute Nachricht ist, aber so richtig scheiße ist
das jetzt auch nicht. KI ist jetzt gut.
Ich bin nur ruhig.
Die tut dir nichts. Die ist ganz lieb.
Nee, gar KI.
Ja, die kannst du auch streicheln. Die beißt nicht.
Die will nur spielen.
Ja.
Das ist jetzt nicht Erpressung. Das ist ja...
Ist halt sehr stark meinungsbehaftet.
Ja,
Übrigens, Thema Erpressung.
Ich habe vor einigen Monaten mit sehr großer Verwunderung eine Presseerklärung
gelesen von einer Kanzlei.
Und zwar von der Kanzlei Scherz-Bergmann.
Eine Kanzlei, also eine Rechtsanwaltskanzlei, die so Leute vertritt wie Till Lindemann,
Jérôme Boateng, Christian Ulmen und andere Leute.
Die plötzlich so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten in ihrer öffentlichen Wahrnehmung erfahren.
Und die Pressemitteilung, die kurz nach dem Spiegeltitel das Verhalten von Christian
Ulm gegenüber seiner damaligen Ehefrau Colleen Fernandes veröffentlicht haben, war,
aus Anlass der aktuellen Spiegel-Berichterstattung zeigen wir an,
dass wir ab sofort und allein die presserechtlichen Interessen von Christian Ulm vertreten.
Die Berichterstattung ist nach summarischer Prüfung aus mehreren Gründen rechtswidrig.
Wir sind daher auch beauftragt, gegen den Spiegel rechtliche Schritte einzuleiten.
Es handelt sich zum einen in großen Teilen um eine unzulässige Verdachtsberichterstattung,
zum anderen werden unwahre Tatsachen aufgrund einer einseitigen Schilderung verbreitet.
Jetzt kommt der entscheidende Satz. Wir bitten daher unbedingt,
die Persönlichkeitsrechte von Herrn Ulmen zu beachten und von einer Übernahme
einseitiger Vorwürfe Abstand zu nehmen.
Man kann darüber schreiben...
Presseerklärung oder Pressemitteilung. Man könnte auch einfach sagen,
das ist ein Drohbrief an die Öffentlichkeit.
Interessanterweise ist dieser Drohbrief voller Tatsachenbehauptungen,
die nach gerichtlicher Prüfung leider nicht den Tatsachen entsprechen.
Denn die haben in ziemlicher voller Breite ich glaube 14 von 16 Punkten vor Gericht verloren.
Und ich finde das sehr interessant, sich mal mit dem Vorgehen dieser Kanzlei auseinander zu setzen.
Weil das sind, also ich meine, wenn ich, also normalerweise gehst du ja zu einer,
Kanzlei, wenn du sagst, okay, hier werden meine Rechte verletzt,
ich interessiere mich dafür,
die zu wahren, wir leben im Rechtsstaat und ab jetzt, bitte mit den Mitteln des Rechtsstaates.
Und Anwälte sind ja Organe der Rechtspflege. Als Organe der Rechtspflege vertritt
er jetzt bitte meine Interessen, auch mit der notwendigen Schärfe,
weil hier, das ist ja alles völlig in Ordnung.
Ist untypisch, also wenn ich jetzt zu einem Anwalt gehen würde,
würde ich sagen, pass auf, ich mach erstmal hier,
auf ey, wir bringen euch trink, wir sind alleine hier, wir sitzen nämlich unser,
wir passen hier auf weißt du, das finde ich halt also,
schwer in also entspricht irgendwie nicht meiner Vorstellung davon,
wie eine Anwaltskanzlei vorgehen würde und die meisten tun das auch nicht,
weil sie nicht wie diese Kanzlei,
Im Prinzip so die öffentliche Meinungskanzlei sind oder die öffentliche Meinungsfreiheitskanzlei
primär damit beschäftigt,
da halt die Leute zu vertreten, die sowas bezahlen können.
Und ich betrachte das ehrlich gesagt mit großem Argwohnen, wie die sich gerieren und wie die agieren.
Und ich hoffe, die hören das. Und ich hoffe, dass ich auch eine Presseerklärung
von dieser Großkanzlei bekomme.
Ich finde das einfach schwach. Also ich finde es wirklich schwach und ich glaube
ehrlich gesagt, sich von denen vertreten zu lassen, also wenn man sich anschaut,
wer die KlientInnen dieser Kanzlei sind, das gibt einem ja schon einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Auch KlientInnen dieser Kanzlei sind, das gibt einem ja auch schon einen ganz guten Eindruck.
In welchen Situationen man sich an solche Leute wendet und Und deswegen betrachte
ich das mit großer Freude,
dass der Spiegel und sein Jurat, sein Legal-Team, die man in die Grenzen gewiesen hat.
Denn derartige, also das ist
halt einfach nur Einschüchterung der Öffentlichkeit, was die da machen.
Und ich bin eigentlich ganz froh, dass der Spiegel sich von so einer Scheiße
nicht einschüchtern lässt.
Und spricht natürlich übrigens auch für die Qualität der Berichterstattung.
Ich meine, bevor die auf das Cover gehen und da draufschreiben,
du hast mich virtuell vergewaltigt, glaube ich schon, dass beim Spiegel so eins,
zwei, drei Leute sagen so.
Lass mal kurz gucken, dass wir uns nicht diese Scherzbergmänner da eintreten.
Und wenn, dass sie rechts und links einen kriegen. Ja, fand ich ganz gut.
Wollte ich erwähnen und ich will das jetzt auch nicht grundsätzlich in Abrede stellen,
dass man unter Umständen auch mal, weiß nicht, wenn eine falsche Berichterstattung
oder so, die wirklich ein großer persönlicher und natürlich für Christian Ulm
auch finanzieller Schaden entsteht,
dass man da sich sehr anstrengt, das abzuwenden.
Aber das tut man eben mit den Mitteln, die das Handwerk der Anwalterei betreffen
und nicht mit irgendwelchen Pressemitteilungen
und Drohbriefen an die Öffentlichkeit. Finde ich schwach.
Und das Ergebnis finde ich gut.
Tja, ist der Ruf erst ruiniert?
Ja.
Giss, giss, Scherz, Bergmann.
Ja, ist der Ruf erst ruiniert? Macht der Bergmann einen Scherz? Naja, aber...
So, dann kommen wir zu einem Hilferuf von unseren Freunden, Freundinnen und
Freunden, die die FrostCon ausrichten.
Genau, die FrostCon ist eine regelmäßig stattfindende und das auch schon seit
einiger Zeit, ich weiß nicht, mindestens seit 20 Jahren stattfindende Konferenz.
Ich hoffe, ich habe das richtig eingeschätzt. Ja, hätte ich auch gedacht,
aber habe ich gerade keine Quelle für, kannst ja mal gucken.
FrostCon steht für Free and Open Source Software Conference,
findet regelmäßig statt in Bonn, dort an der Universität und immer so kurz bevor
es wieder losgeht mit dem Semester, also im Sommer, übrigens auch in diesem Jahr am 15.
Und 16. August, 26.
Aber wir erwähnen das jetzt nicht, weil die Veranstaltung ist,
sondern auch nicht, weil sie schon seit dem April einen CFP draußen haben,
den ihr zur Kenntnis nehmen könnt, sondern weil sie einen Hilferuf ausgesendet haben.
Denn, so schreibt Scotty, wir haben dieses Jahr massive Probleme,
genügend Partner zu finden, um die Frostkorn zu finanzieren.
Deshalb haben wir uns entschlossen, euch alle um eure Hilfe zu bitten.
Wenn ihr ein paar Euros übrig habt und wollt, dass die Frostcon auch dieses
und die nächsten 20 Jahre stattfinden kann, könnt ihr uns eine Spende da lassen
und zwar auf einer entsprechenden Seite auf Beta Place.
Die haben einen Trägerverein, der gemeinnützig ist, das heißt kriegt er auch
eine Spendenbescheinigung.
Warst du mal auf der Frostcon? Nein, ich war da noch nie.
Es ist immer eine ungünstige Terminlage.
Aber man kann sich ja die Aufzeichnung der Froscon auf media.ccc.de anschauen.
Das verlinken wir auch nochmal.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen Home of the Walk. Also mit der FrostCon hat sich
sehr viel von diesem Video Operation Center technisch mitentwickelt.
Das ist so die Community, aus der das auch hervorgekommen ist.
Das heißt, die FrostCon war dann auch schon so ein bisschen die Geburtsstätte
dieser Open Source Bewegung.
Also wer nicht weiß, wovon wir reden, das ist die Videoaufzeichnungstechnik,
die dann letztlich auf dem Kongress vor allem immer zum Tragen kommt,
aber mittlerweile auch über das Jahr hinweg wirklich von Event zu Event geschickt wird.
Da sind also große Rollkoffer mit Technik drin und die ganze Software,
mit der das betrieben wird, ist dort entwickelt worden und beliefert sozusagen
alle Konferenzen mehr oder weniger zu einem Selbstkostenpreis und trägt damit
schon mal ganz erheblich dazu bei,
dass halt nicht nur technische Veranstaltungen,
sondern auch so netzpolitische Veranstaltungen damit unterstützt werden.
Und viel liegt halt sozusagen auch in diesem Geburtsort, der Frostkorn begründet.
Das ist nicht das einzige Argument dafür. Es ist halt überhaupt so ein Ort neben
der, wie heißt die andere Veranstaltung in Brüssel, in Belgien,
die Open Source Konferenz. Nee.
Vergessen, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall Frostkorn, alles gut.
Ich war mal da, ist eine Menge los und sehr viele Entwickler dort,
wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt.
Frostem. Genau, das meinte ich.
Genau.
So ein bisschen ein Äquivalent. Ja, so wie dazu.
Ja.
Ich glaube, also ich finde, ich lege ich auch mal in die Shownotes,
2025 gibt es ein Talk über 20 Jahre Frostkommen.
Habe ich richtig geraten.
Und genau, den Link haben wir in den Shownotes, bei Better Place.
Das ist eine moderate Summe. Ich glaube, das brauchen wir so 25.000 oder sowas.
Wir suchen ungefähr 30.000 Euro brauchen sie. Von denen haben sie,
krass. Sie haben jetzt schon,
11.000 zusammen, aber aus 50 Spenden.
Da hat aber einer.
Ja, ich meine Unternehmen, die von Open Source profitieren, können sich bei
solchen Veranstaltungen durchführen.
Ja, da kannst du durchaus mal, also ja. aber die Spenden Da triffst.
Du immer die Richtigen.
Da sind, also ne das ist schon,
entscheidend entscheidende und auch nicht irgendeine Konferenz,
so wenn du dir über die Jahre anschaust was da an,
Vortragenden war und auch an Themen gesetzt wurde ja ich bin auch relativ sicher,
dass die dass sie es schaffen werden,
diesen Betrag zusammenzubekommen.
Vor allem dank euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Ah, guck mal, sie haben auch gesagt, was sie da brauchen, wofür.
Infrastruktur, Konferenzprogramm, also Backstage-Catering. Aha!
Da wollen, oh, das Backstage-Catering.
Schnittchen. Na toll.
Ach, man kann quasi auch überlegen, man kann offenbar hier,
Gezielt für einen Bereich Spenden.
Zum Beispiel für das Konfensprogramm.
Konfensprogramm?
Ja, da musst du nochmal.
Konfensprogramm.
Da ist wohl auch keine KI drüber gelaufen hier.
Ja, Konfensprogramm. Da müssen wir dem Scotty mal gleich Bescheid sagen.
So geht es ja nicht hier.
Konfensprogramm würde ich auch haben.
So, ja okay. Wir machen jetzt hier auch mal Schluss.
Moment, jetzt verstehe ich das erstmal. Die meisten Leute haben für das Catering gespendet bisher.
Das ist wirklich so. Beim Catering fehlen dreieinhalbtausend.
Ah ja.
Beim Confidence-Programm, da
wissen die Leute halt nicht, was das ist und sagen, so kann man das essen.
Infrastruktur interessiert keinen.
Infrastruktur ist kackegal.
Schnittchen. Naja.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es dann bei dem Backstage-Catering vielleicht
eine Großspende gab von jemandem, der sich überlegt hat, als allererstes will
ich mal die Volunteers füttern.
Ja, Liebe geht durch den Magen.
Ja, oder vor allem, dass die da nicht umkippen.
Ja, das noch dazu.
Alright, ich denke, jetzt haben wir es.
Wir sollten vielleicht noch sagen, wann die FrostCon stattfindet.
Habe ich schon gesagt. 15. und 16. August 26.
Und gibt es da auch ein Conference-Programm?
Dass genug Kohle zusammenkommt. Vielleicht, sonst sitzen sie da nur und es gibt nur ein Schnittchen.
Das Konferenzprogramm hat keiner für gespendet.
Deswegen ist es gerade noch ein Konferenzprogramm. Wenn man jetzt ein R und ein E kauft.
Also Leute, wer schon immer nochmal Buchstaben kaufen wollte,
go ahead. Ihr findet sicherlich den richtigen Button.
So, das war es jetzt hier mit unserer Konfenz. Wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald.
Bis bald. Ciao, ciao.